smell like money
[Applause]
hey what's poppin GQ this is what your
guiding these are my essentials this is
my first essentials it may look like a
bag it's actually the cash man you know
every day I delete walk-around least
feed the cake on me so there's like 60
right here I've been spinning out of it
I think this was a honey when I started
all but just like 60,000 veteran
pointing since you that I have cash on
me every day no I don't do credit cards
I don't do credit cards come on mama
told me back in the day
she never dated a man who totally won it
I mean he having no money cash is
essential
I miss my next accenture there's no good
pain just wide shot off my nose down all
my ideas different things that I'm
thinking of I have a job to jot it down
right here there's no good pair
I'm stealing like all analog do not not
really digital I don't put things in my
notes on the phone I still write them
down so I see now I don't write raps
down all my reps coming off the top of
the eighth
I used to write raps on my first
daughter and that was over ten years I
feel like even delivery Bella are you
just coming off the top in the booth is
that like expression ovary my next
reception cologne smell like money you
know I mean it's custom to me it's ACMG
Kol honour CMG is the label Calum is
king of Memphis sent out 33 hi my Nexus
said she's always to keep a pair of
poems with me that would know what
get it to the fullest wait I got a new
soul my favorite color is white I'll try
to keep it fresh pearl white he saw me
at all time
I've been right the Pullman since air -
oh jeez make any day the Pullman light
my go-to kicks right now yeah I got a
collection listen because I probably got
over 200 pair of clothes my favorite
pool of all time man I like the new ones
I like the new ones he knows that Irish
make the class and the oh jeez
I really like how they make it new ones
you know I'm saying with all the colors
and making them fun I have to keep this
like a conviction of watch so just like
a million dollars worth for watch I
carry with me every day I got one alone
so that's why I'm missing a slot right
here but all these is different type of
watches you got rich your meal Richard
Mille Patek platinum Rolex flooded out
ap another flood of that ap jay-z
actually gave me this watcher as an
invitation to a fundraiser gala so it is
watch [ __ ] it to me and I'm missing my
slap which is the owners potato this on
my wrist right now like I said just like
I mean other words watch it's not I
carry with me depending on what clothes
what outfit I wear I'm swamped watches
just watch her you know like three
hundred thousand right now so this is
one of my favorite watches like close to
me just depending on what I'm worried if
I got all some read it sporty but still
a Richard Mille I got on a whole outfit
right now and he's 40 would he still a
potato honey I would watch how the penis
everywhere I go I keep a lot of ice on
me
cuz I don't know when we'd like to
celebrate so I keep a bought an ice on
me in case we got to celebrate another
win and let the pop a bottle of
champagne I've been drinking a just fate
far as I can remember
I'm og to a smeii game I only drink ace
of spade and do say don't drink that
know oh we popped eggman bottles last
night I had a gun oh I had a listening
party and gonna hit the foe season last
night in man was a space shower and you
know saying we a spade fellas blowing do
safely flooring all night
[Music]
I did my Knicks essentials you practice
safe he'll say hey I think you shall
always keep one of these keep these with
you because you never know how to make
me I need Magnum we call them gold boys
yeah heaven on earth this is another one
of my cinches Louie duffle actually I
collect bake cakes and duffels just one
of my favorite ones and that way I can
carry all my other essentials inside of
this essential again is our personality
our personality what you like you know
be sure you drink come with like
personality well how you feeling what
you rockin different different flavors
for different people
[Music]
another one of my senses of damage I
like the world a lot of damage you see
on my wrists around my neck you know I
just like damage so everywhere I go I
don't have only suffer damage today a
light David vehicle you know sometimes
I'm a rock Cubans sometimes I keep
yourself when I just run that was was
crazy chaining boat was on I am some
canary yellow diamonds decree almost oh
not the ones I use an enhancement lays
in hands mister to change the damage
different colors and to make a cheapo
damn and look like you have more quality
in it but they ain't worth nothing when
they try to resell it how the value is
out of it all but on it
my very first yo guided piece it was the
Y always yellow and the guy that was
white but it was real canary all the
damage they were like one of my first
chains I bought it I spent a lot of
money on me right now
he's returned his product like see like
450 450 down
just the dam is not to watch so I got
our leave Amber's her from mcvinnie
jewel of naming pretty well here in New
York with our vehicle company I bought
all three these chains and once I bought
all the brushes at once
and then the Rings this is my marriage
ring to the street mayor to the game is
my wedding band for the streets these
just forget bracelet it's just some cool
fun bracelets it's raining right here
pretty cool that was all around it and
then the Debbie changes this water real
buddy okay I have three phones which is
my favorite one this might go too far
it's like my favorite iPhone of all the
time so I get the new ones when they
come out but I always keep this they're
going to pop you easy you know I'm
saying they easy to handle easy to keep
up wit it's like my favorite phone I
love this phone also my phone is babies
another phone his family and mr. HOF oh
they have an alert phone
[Music]
you know it it should what you've got
appreciate y'all for checking out my
essentials into next time I'm out